peu
obama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
niveau fatigue pas un peu ce personnage
satanique on me pose la question parce
que s'il est le sixième dont camille
avait été un don camillo
conventionnelles comme les autres je ne
l'aurais pas fait car alors il ya eu
toujours des trois personnages dont
camille au bacon et jésus melania eu une
idée parce que il y à là jeunesse
actuelle et forcément il ya le concile
alors tant qu'ami aussi n'est pas
d'accord ni sur la nouvelle messe ni sur
la messe en français ni sur les maoïstes
ni sur les hippies forcément alors ça
amène vraiment un climat tout à fait
spéciale en conservant quand même
toujours les scènes avec jésus et les
scènes avec l'époque lui était passé
mais pas le dépasser par son fils kim
aris et ma nièce qui est dit
deux ventes par an par la force des
choses puisque à la fin
les deux jeunes se marient comme c'est
ma nièce je deviens le grande ombre du
body l'espoir mais vise haut risque ce
que ça donne
alors comme c'est le dire ni passer le
dernier tant est que vous restiez mans
on n'a pas pu après c'est le dernier je
vois que le dernier sera assez original
les chrétiens jacques trets à un film
drôle tout en conservant malgré tout la
personnalité des rôles de don camillo
qu'ils ont fait par exemple la commedia
dell arte
j'avais même le personnage de jésus dans
ce film le downtown n'est ce pas parce
que il m'a toujours donné tort
d'ailleurs mais là encore plus que je me
plante des cheveux longs des fils de
vespone il m'a dit moi aussi j'avais les
cheveux longs et tout ce que je dis
raccords de vraiment avec ce qu'était
jesus luz est un film contestataire ou
anti contestataires je redis c'est donc
amis et c'est comme tu as ta terre parce
que lui comme c'est attirant surtout ne
veut pas admettre à la messe dite de
phase il faut conserver la baisse dit
dodo
or on lui a il a un col jitter qui lui
arrive sans soutane et nous dit pas les
choses aller vous habiller parce que moi
j'aime pas les bourgeois il me dit mais
je veux m'appuyer pas je reste comme ça
alors tout et vendre au moins à
déterminer quand normalement j'aurais
terminé mois le 15 septembre si tout va
bien
est-ce que tout va bien dans le film
jamais or non
on a ça heureusement ça s'est passé oui
[Musique]